I'd be very surprised that we're not
looking at unemployment rate over ten
percent by the end of the year and quite
likely crossing eleven percent sometime
next year in a good case scenario we'll
start to see the unemployment rate
coming down in 2010 but it's still it's
still like they'd be in double digits by
the end of 2010 but that's that's what's
really front and center now how long
does it take us to get back to a more
normal unemployment rate that's going to
depend a huge amount of policy I think
we very badly need another stimulus
probably even larger than the last round
at this point there's little political
will in Congress and certainly the Obama
administration to take the lead on that
but my hope is that as the economy
continues to deteriorate I don't hope
that continues to deteriorate but as
that will happen I think it will only
delay in two ways about it that you will
see more pressure on Congress to do
something about it so that by the summer
you do have people talking about another
round of stimulus so if that happens we
do get a big boost the economy then they
come and could start to recover more
quickly and perhaps next scenario we
will see the unemployment rate under ten
percent by the end of two thousand